[inaudible]
falls couple of years ago, I was
Raven about that John Fabro movie.
I'm a chef. You haven't
seen the movie. It's,
it's phenomenal. It's just such
a great, great movie. And uh,
and just don't be hungry when
you watch it because you will,
you will consume like 12,000 calories
after watching it because some of the
food, basically, all of the food
that they make looks unbelievable.
So long story short, you know,
like whenever they have like end
credit stuff on like a movie, um,
you know,
it's usually like outtakes or something
from the actress screwing up or, or,
or whatever. Um,
okay.
John had to learn how to basically,
I guess, you know, they had data,
you had to take cooking classes and stuff.
So he looked like he was an actual chef.
So though the movie movies
character would ring true, you know,
all that actory stuff.
So there was a guy showing them how to
make a grilled cheese sandwich. This guy,
a chef, Roy Choi, who, uh,
had the Koji trucks started the whole
food truck movement out here in la and
everything. And
it all started with the
Kogi Barbecue Taco truck.
There's nothing else in life they could
have brought me this far to feed so many
people yet there's so many
people I haven't fed yet
and as his restaurant empire
continues to grow,
Choy is determined to feed people in
underserved communities with nutritious
fast food at his restaurant chain called
local and Roy Choi isn't amused by
critics who he says want him to fail.
He was showing them how to do it and
John just decided to film it when he,
when he,
when he was making this cheeseburger and
it was like so fucking intense when the
guy was doing like all
crunched down looking at it
and he was moving the grilled
cheese grilled cheese sandwich.
You just thinking like this is something
like a fucking 12 year old can make,
but watching this guy do it
and the level of intensity,
the game seven fucking intensity
that this guy had when he made it,
I was just like, what? They'd
like blew me away. It was like,
I've never been that into fucking
cook consulting ever. You know?
Ah, it doesn't make sense
with my brains and your speed.
We should be destined
for greatness, right?
We need to think big little Amigo.
I'm talking commercials. Talk shows,
Connie fairs. Got It. We can
have our very own Telanovela
[inaudible].